ONE OF THE FIRST DOCTORS TO SEE
IT FIRSTHAND.
HEAR WHAT SHE SAYS ABOUT THE
PATIENTS' CONDITIONS.
YOU MIGHT BE SURPRISED.
>> LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT.
>>> A PHONE CALL BETWEEN
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN BOEBERT
AND OMAR DIDN'T DO A LOT AFTER
BOEBERT INSINUATED OMAR WAS A
SUICIDE BOMBER.
HERE IS HOW BOEBERT DESCRIBED
THE PHONE CALL.
>> I NEVER WANT ANYTHING I SAY
TO OFFEND SOMEONE'S RELIGION.
I TOLD HER THAT.
SHE KEPT ASKING FOR A PUBLIC
APOLOGY.
I TOLD OMAR THAT SHE SHOULD MAKE
A PUBLIC APOLOGY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR HER ANTI-AMERICAN,
ANTI-SEMITIC, ANTI-POLICE
RHETORIC.
>> SO OMAR REPORTEDLY HUNG UP ON
BOEBERT, AND THEN SHE ISSUED THE
FOLLOWING STATEMENT.
INSTEAD OF APOLOGIZING FOR HER
ISLAMAPHOBIC COMMENTS AND LIES,
CONGRESSWOMAN BOEBERT DIDN'T
ACKNOWLEDGE HER HURTFUL COMMENTS
BUT DOUBLED DOWN ON THE
RHETORIC, SO I DECIDED TO END
THE CALL.
I WANT TO ENGAGE THOSE WE
DISAGREE WITH RESPECTFULLY, BUT
NOT WHEN IT IS ROOTED IN
OUTRIGHT BIGOTRY AND HATE.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH
CONGRESSWOMAN DEBBIE DINGELL OF
MICHIGAN.
IT IS SAD TO WATCH THIS BACK AND
FORTH.
I WONDER WHAT YOUR REACTION IS
TO IT.
>> YOU KNOW, I'M REALLY -- WELL,
GOOD MORNING.
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE WATCHING AND WITNESSING
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED IS IN
THE HALLS OF CONGRESS WHICH IS
THE HEART OF DEMOCRACY.
BUT WE HAVE SCENES LIKE THAT
PLAYING OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS COUNTRY IS BEING DIVIDED BY
FEAR AND HATRED AND VIOLENCE.
WE NEED TO ALL TAKE A DEEP
BREATH.
WE CAN DISAGREE WITH EACH OTHER.
WE CAN DO IT RESPECTFULLY.
WE NEED TO RESPECT EACH AND
EVERY INDIVIDUAL, WHOEVER THEY
ARE, WHEREVER THEY CAME FROM,
WHATEVER THEIR RELIGION IS.
I JUST WOULD LIKE EVERYBODY IN
THIS COUNTRY TO TAKE A DEEP,
COLLECTIVE BREATH, AND START TO
THINK ABOUT THE HATEFUL THINGS
WE ARE BEGINNING TO ACCEPT AS
OKAY.
>> WHAT DO YOU WORRY THAT THAT
KIND OF THING WILL SPAWN?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I'M GOING TO
TALK A LITTLE ABOUT WHAT I'VE
WITNESSED.
YOU KNOW, A YEAR AGO, WHEN MEN
WERE AT THE CAPITOL WITH ASSAULT
WEAPONS, NOT WEARING GLOVES OR
MASKS, HANDING OUT CANDY,
BLOCKING EMERGENCY ROOMS, I
DEFENDED MY GOVERNOR.
PEOPLE SHOWED UP OUTSIDE MY
HOUSE WITH ASSAULT WEAPONS.
I THINK MANY CONGRESSIONAL
OFFICES -- I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS
MOST -- BUT I HAVE YOUNG STAFF
WHO REALLY ARE WANTING TO HELP,
CARE ABOUT THE WORLD.
THEY HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THEY'RE ALSO ANSWERING PHONES
WITH HATE AND THE SPEWING OF
THINGS THAT, IN MY -- WHEN I WAS
YOUNG, I WOULD HAVE -- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
WE WERE JUST TAUGHT THAT YOU
DON'T ACT THIS WAY.
SO MANY PEOPLE WAYS.
MY YOUNG PEOPLE ARE SCARED, AND
I SEE IT ACROSS THE HILL.
MY COLLEAGUE, FRED UPTON, WHO
GOT EVISCERATED FOR VOTING FOR
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, FOR
BRINGING MONEY HOME TO HIS
DISTRICT FOR ROADS AND BRIDGES
AND INTERNET, GETTING LEAD OUT
OF PIPE, HIS STAFF WAS RATTLED.
HE DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE
CRITIQUE, BUT HE WAS WORRIED
ABOUT HIS FAMILY AND HIS STAFF.
THIS HAS TO STOP.
IT IS SIMPLY NOT OKAY.
>> DO YOU WORRY THAT CONGRESS
WILL ACTUALLY LOSE TALENT, THAT
THEY WILL LOSE TALENTED PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THESE CONCERNS?
>> I VERY MUCH WORRY ABOUT IT.
I TALK TO PEOPLE WHO ARE, LIKE,
WHY WOULD I -- FIRST OF ALL,
THEY WONDER WHY THEY,
THEMSELVES, WOULD WANT TO DO IT,
BUT THEY CARE ABOUT THEIR
FAMILIES.
THEY LOVE THEIR FAMILIES.
THEY CARE ABOUT PEOPLE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO PUT PEOPLE
THAT THEY LOVE OR CARE FOR AT
RISK.
AND WE CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN.
WE NEED PEOPLE OF ALL KINDS OF
BACKGROUNDS.
THAT'S WHAT THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IS.
IT IS A REPRESENTATIVE BODY OF
THIS COUNTRY WHO WANT TO SERVE.
PUBLIC SERVICE IS GOOD, AND IT
IS ONLY AS GOOD AS THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE WILLING TO RUN AND
FIGHT AND BE PART OF -- TO FIGHT
FOR OUR FREEDOM, TO PROTECT OUR
DEMOCRACY, PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUTION, BUT DO IT IN A
CIVIL, RESPECTFUL, DIGNIIED
WAY.
>> WHAT DOES LEADERSHIP DO,
THOUGH, WHEN, SAY, YOU KNOW,
DISCIPLINING LAUREN BOEBERT
HERE, CENSURING HERE, IT
ACTUALLY JUST SEEMS TO GIVE
LAUREN BOEBERTS AND PAUL GOSARS
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT AND,
HONESTLY, POLITICALLY, WHAT THEY
NEED?
>> I'M TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
I, BY THE WAY, REPRESENT THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF ARAB
AMERICANS IN THE COUNTRY.
I'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
BIGOTRY AND HATRED AND THREATS
SINCE I GOT ELECTED AND, QUITE
FRANKLY, BEFORE I WAS ELECTED,
BECAUSE OF OTHER THINGS.
THIS COMMUNITY REALLY HURTS.
IT REALLY -- THEY'RE AMERICANS.
HERE'S SOMETHING I WANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE OF, ONE OF THE
WORST INCIDENTS OF TERRORISM IN
THIS COUNTRY WAS IN OKLAHOMA BY
YOUNG, WHITE MEN WHO WERE
MEMBERS OF THE MICHIGAN MILITIA.
WE CANNOT LOOK AT SOMEBODY AND
JUDGE THEM OR HAVE BUILT-IN
IDEAS OR THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY
ARE.
WE NEED TO RESPECT EVERYBODY,
AND I MEAN EVERYBODY.
I THINK WE'VE GOT TO FIND A WAY.
I REALLY AM FOCUSED ON THIS
COLLECTIVE, DEEP BREATH.
THIS TIT FOR TAT, TIT FOR TAT,
IT IS, YOU KNOW -- I WAS READING
GANDHI LAST NIGHT.
I WAS UPSET ABOUT SOME THINGS.
YOU KNOW, AN EYE FOR AN EYE
LEAVES EVERYBODY BLIND.
WE HAVE TO START TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO TONE DOWN,
COLLECTIVELY, THIS ANGER, THIS
VITRIOL IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> I WISH MORE PEOPLE WERE
READING GANDHI, CONGRESSWOMAN.
I DO WANT TO ASK YOU, BECAUSE
YOUR OFFICE IN DEARBORN WAS
VANDALIZED YESTERDAY, BROKEN
INTO.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WAS BEHIND
THIS?
>> I DON'T.
WHEN THE POLICE CALLED ME, I MET
THEM OVER THERE AT THE OFFICE.
NONE OF MY TECHNOLOGY WAS TAKEN.
THEY HAD TAKEN SOME PADDLES,
PATRIOTIC PADDLES THAT HAD BEEN
GIVEN TO ME, TAKING IT AND
DAMAGED MEMORABILIA OF MY
HUSBAND.
POLICE SAID IT WAS PERSONAL.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY THAT IT
DIDN'T BOTHER ME, BUT I HAVE
REMOVED ALL THE IMPORTANT
MEMORABILIA, THINGS THAT HAVE
SENTIMENTAL OR HISTORICAL VALUE
TO ME, FROM THE OFFICE, AND I'M
GOING BACK OUT TODAY AND DOING
MY JOB.
>> I'M REALLY SORRY FOR THAT,
CONGRESSWOMAN.
THAT MUST HAVE BEEN VERY
UPSETTING, TO LOSE SOME MEME
--
MEMORABILIA RELATED TO YOUR LATE
HUSBAND.
I APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US
THIS MORNING.
>> THANK YOU